autre élément à retenir sandrine c'est
que cette invasion russe de l'ukraine a
poussé sur la voie de l'exil quelques 4
millions de personnes environ le cap a
été franchi cette semaine selon l'onu
oui l'envoyé spécial de france 24
pauline godard est de retour à méditer à
la frontière polonaise elle a traversé
la frontière elle s'est rendue à chailly
niasse et en ukraine elle a pu y voir là
bas ce flot de réfugiés qui attendent de
pouvoir passer l'autre côté on les
écoute
nous avons pu constater que côté
ukrainien achat il n'ya à la frontière
l'aide humanitaire est bien moins
présentes il y à quelques tentes qui
distribuent de quoi manger des boissons
chaudes et imperméables il ya aussi
certains volontaires qui viennent aider
par exemple à transporter les personnes
âgées ou handicapées mais rien à voir
avec de l'autre côté du côté polonais à
medica où nous nous trouvons
actuellement c'est pour cela qu'il y ait
aussi des volontaires qui passent la
frontière avec de la nourriture et des
couvertures car il ya beaucoup de
besoins côté ukrainien il fait froid
comme vous pouvez le voir il pleut
également les ukrainiens attendre
plusieurs heures avant de pouvoir passer
la frontière quand nous sommes partis là
files d'attentes avait encore grandi ils
étaient plusieurs centaines nous avons
pu parler avec une femme elle nous a
expliqué venir dire pin avec ses enfants
elle a fait le trajet en voiture un
trajet qui aura duré plus de 12 heures
au lieu des quatre heures habituelles
ils ont dû contourner les bombardements
nous at elle expliqué elle s'est ensuite
effondrée en pleurs une fois là le poste
frontière passée côté ukrainien un peu
plus loin il y à une tente pour ceux qui
veulent rejoindre la légion nous avons
parlé avec ceux qui tiennent cette tante
ils nous ont expliqué que pour intégrer
la légion il faut avoir de l'expérience
militaire et fournira un papier officiel
qui atteste de votre expérience une fois
les papiers vérifier ces volontaires
sont conduits dans un centre militaire
où ils suivent une formation pendant
quinze jours et puis ils partent au
combat ils ne savent pas en avance où
ils iront il ya beaucoup de polonais
d'américains et d'israéliens nous
ont-ils confié